we were excited about making a
traditional dragon feast and then it hit
me not everyone was on board yeah Zephir
what are you doing
testing my dragon defense system see you
and all the grown-ups an uber car
leaving them snacks what if one shows up
that would be great
we love dragons why they're monsters I
found this in the Attic
it was grandpa's how come you never told
us the truth about dragons but we did
dragons are wonderful they're our
friends
tell me this are they giant well yeah
razor-sharp teeth breathe fire I suppose
oh maybe we don't leave fish snacks
around to attract them cuz you know who
doesn't want to be dragon dessert me
nothing do you want to be dessert for a
dragon hmm methinks I don't
how did this happen our ancestors were
terrified of dragons because they didn't
know them Astrid we cannot let our kids
go down that road remember when we were
kids back in old Berk how we used to put
on a pageant ATS novel dog oh yeah
those were fun what if we brought the
pageant back we showed the children of
newburgh how humans and Dragons became
friends that's a great idea
but we've only got four days until snarl
targeting three if you don't count black
plate Friday yeah nothing gets done
everybody's just shopping and coughing I
think we could do this let's talk to
Gobber
[Music]
kid can take a hit
Hey are you okay
yeah yeah it's just all this talk of
dragons kind of makes me miss him it's
hard at the holidays you know wonderful
iseven s's me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]